- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Bonjour.
Madame la Première
ministre, mesdames
et messieurs les membres
du gouvernement,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
mes chers collègues,
ces derniers jours,
deux tempêtes ont balayé
la France métropolitaine,
de la Bretagne à Corse,
occasionnant d'importants dégâts
et causant la mort
d'au moins trois personnes.
D'autres pays sont touchés
par ce phénomène climatique
exceptionnel, qui met
durement à l'épreuve
notre capacité
de résilience collective.
Des milliers de foyers ont été
privés d'électricité.
90.000 connaissent
encore des coupures.
De nombreux voyageurs
ont été bloqués
pendant plusieurs heures
dans des trains
à l'arrêt.
Le Pas-de-Calais
est toujours en alerte
le rouge et six départements
demeurent
en vigilance orange.
Dans ces départements,
j'en appelle
à la vigilance de tous.
Des crues exceptionnelles
sont en cours.
Malgré les risques, les élus,
les collectivités territoriales,
les services de secours,
nos forces
de l'ordre et tous
les services de l'Etat
se sont mobilisés
et continuent de l'être
pour rétablir au plus vite
les conditions
de vie normale et secourir
les personnes.
Pas moins de 100.000
agents de la SNCF
sont intervenus
pour dégager
plus de 2000 arbres
tombés sur les voies.
Je voudrais
que nous saluions ensemble
le travail de ces équipes
qui ont pu mettre
en place des services de bus
de substitution également.
Applaudissements
Au nom de la représentation
nationale,
je veux rendre
hommage à l'ensemble
des pompiers, secouristes,
policiers, gendarmes,
agents publics
et bénévoles
qui n'ont pas ménagé
leurs efforts
au service de leurs concitoyens.
Ils méritent notre estime
et notre reconnaissance.
Parmi les victimes, il y a
un agent d'Enedis.
Il est décédé en service,
électrocuté.
Il était venu du Gers
pour secourir
les abonnés du Finistère.
En sa mémoire,
je vous demande
de bien vouloir
observer une minute
de silence.
Je vous remercie.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première d'entre
elles va être posée
par monsieur
Marcellin Nadeau,
pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et républicaine.
- Marcellin Nadeau:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Catherine Colonna.
Madame la ministre,
dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien,
les pays occidentaux
en appellent à la trêve
et tentent d'apparaître
comme les garants
du droit international
mais ils abdiquent
devant la loi
du plus fort.
L'humanité, ce n'est pas cela.
Nous devons affirmer
l'absolue nécessité
d'un cessez-le-feu
immédiat et le rappel
de la solution
des deux Etats préconisée
par l'ONU.
Nous devons éviter
que ce conflit
soit une guerre
de civilisation
dans laquelle une démocratie
se défendrait
contre des barbares,
comme au bon vieux temps
des guerres coloniales.
Le conflit
aujourd'hui
n'est-il pas le résultat
de deux logiques extrêmes
qui ont empêché
la solution
de deux Etats démocratiques?
La convention de Genève
doit être respectée.
Au moment
où cette convention
était signée, les guerres
coloniales faisaient rage.
Aujourd'hui, ce n'est
plus possible.
Nous devons apprendre
de l'histoire.
Nous devons savoir
en tirer des leçons.
Il n'y a plus de barbares!
Les crimes de guerre ne peuvent
justifier l'excès
de cruauté.
Une violence ne peut
se justifier
par la nécessité de la guerre.
L'horreur ne peut en aucun cas
justifier l'horreur.
De l'Ukraine à Gaza,
la France doit
être claire face
au droit des peuples
à disposer d'eux-mêmes.
Face au non-respect
du droit humanitaire
et aux crimes
de guerre,
dans les deux cas,
le droit international
est violé.
Nous attendons
dans ce conflit
que la France soit porteuse
des valeurs démocratiques,
du respect de tous
les peuples
et des exigences
du droit international.
Cela passe
par un cessez-le-feu immédiat!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Laurence Boone,
secrétaire d'Etat
chargée de l'Europe.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
je vous prie
de bien vouloir
excuser la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères,
qui est au Japon
pour une réunion
du G7.
Il y a un mois jour pour jour,
la barbarie terroriste s'est
abattue sur Israël.
Elle a fait 1400 morts,
dont 40 Français.
9 de nos compatriotes
sont encore portés disparus,
dont plusieurs mineurs.
Je pense d'abord
à ces Français meurtris
par le terrorisme du Hamas.
Merci.
Face au Hamas,
nous avons une ligne
très claire:
Israël doit protéger
sa population
et les Palestiniens
ne doivent pas être sacrifiés
à la lutte
contre ce groupe terroriste.
Face à la catastrophe
humanitaire
à Gaza, nous disons deux choses.
D'abord, une trêve humanitaire
est absolument nécessaire.
Nous y appelons avec force.
Un consensus soutenu
par la France
a été conclu sur ce point.
La communauté
internationale a validé
cette volonté
à l'assemblée générale
des Nations Unies.
Deuxièmement,
et vous serez d'accord,
il nous faut
reconnaître que l'aide
n'est pas à la hauteur
de la situation.
Nous devons collectivement
faire davantage, et vite.
C'est pourquoi
la France organise
le 9 novembre à Paris
une conférence humanitaire
internationale
pour la population civile de Gaza.
Nous sommes pratiques
et en action
sur le terrain.
Il s'agira d'apporter
une réponse
à Gaza.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Viry
pour le groupe Républicains.
- Stéphane Viry:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Alors que le projet
de loi visant
au plein emploi a fait l'objet
d'une CNP conclusive,
je m'interroge
sur la capacité
de notre économie à y contribuer.
La situation économique
de la France peut
être contredite par les chiffres.
Les difficultés
s'accumulent
pour nos commerçants
et nos artisans.
Les coûts d'approvisionnement
sont toujours
plus chers,
l'énergie est toujours
très élevée,
les taux d'intérêt
sont à haut niveau.
L'horizon est sombre.
A ce jour, la France
ne crée plus d'emplois.
17.000 emplois supprimés
dans le secteur privé
ces derniers mois.
Le chômage repart à la hausse.
La productivité
de notre pays a diminué.
Les faillites menacent en cascade.
Partout
sur le territoire,
et dans tous
les secteurs d'activité,
des entreprises
sont sous tension
et sur le fil du rasoir.
Pour certaines,
elles sont dans l'incapacité
de rembourser leurs prêts
dans les temps.
Le prêt garanti
par l'Etat qui a été mis
en place
pendant la crise,
il est en train de devenir
un fardeau
pour les entreprises.
S'ils arrivent
à le rembourser
pour l'instant,
c'est au prix du renoncement
à investir ou à embaucher.
Que comptez-vous faire?
Quelle solution
avez-vous pour enrayer
ces cessations de paiements
et ces faillites?
Pour soulager
ces entreprises,
et éviter
que le chômage reparte
à la hausse?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs,
nous n'ignorons pas
l'inquiétude
qui monte, notamment
chez les petits patrons,
les artisans et les petites
entreprises, notamment
sur le remboursement
de leurs prêts garantis
par l'Etat.
Ce prêt a été utile
pour les aider
à passer la crise du Covid.
Les chiffres
de la Banque de France
nous indiquent le que le taux
de défaut anticipé
des PGE est très faible.
La dernière estimation
donne un chiffre
en légère baisse, de 4,6 à 4,4%.
Vous l'avez dit,
nous le savons,
je suis bien
consciente qu'il faut
se méfier des moyennes,
qui cachent
en réalité des situations
bien différentes
et disparates
entre les entreprises.
Plus de 800.000 PGE
ont été délivrés,
cela représente
un montant
de plus de 140
milliards d'euros
pendant la crise Covid.
Les entrepreneurs
sont responsables,
et pour la plupart,
ils parviennent
à rembourser
leur PGE au prix
de moins d'investissements.
Lorsque l'on a un PGE
de moins de 50.000 euros,
on peut échelonner
la durée de son PGE
sans condition
et sans conséquence.
On peut le rembourser
sur 10 ans
au lieu de 6 ans.
Au-delà de 50.000 euros,
on peut renégocier
avec le tribunal de commerce
en se rapprochant
du conseiller en charge
des entreprises
en difficulté à la préfecture.
L'ensemble des conseillers
sont mobilisés.
20.000 entrepreneurs
ont été accompagnés.
Le moment est compliqué,
mais ils tiennent
le coup.
Vous parlez de ces 17.000
emplois perdus,
mais c'est 130.000 emplois
qui ont été créés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
- Stéphane Viry:
Je reçois votre réponse.
Il n'en demeure pas
moins que partout
sur le territoire,
la trésorerie
des entreprises plonge.
Les signes d'inquiétude
sont légion.
Coûte que coûte,
il faudra une action
du gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Mélanie Thomin
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Mélanie Thomin:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la Première
ministre, si,
dans le Pas-de-Calais,
des milliers d'habitants
sont sinistrés sous les eaux,
les Finistériens
ont été éprouvés
par la tempête Ciaran,
sa violence et les dégâts subis.
Ils ont fait remonter
le souvenir dévastateur
de l'ouragan de 87.
TPE, PME et agriculteurs payent
un lourd tribut.
Le président
de la République s'est rendu
dans ma circonscription,
auprès
des producteurs
de fraises de Plougastel,
pour porter un engagement fort.
Il a promis de décréter l'état
de catastrophe naturelle partout
où on pourra le faire.
Pouvez-vous
nous expliquer comment
la tempête Ciaran
peut être classée
en catastrophe naturelle?
La loi exclut
de fait les tempêtes
du régime des catastrophes
et des calamités agricoles.
Ce que le président
a annoncé
n'est pas clair.
Un grand nombre
d'exploitants
sont très inquiets,
ils attendent
des précisions
concrètes concernant
les promesses présidentielles.
Pour ne pas compromettre
leur activité
et la survie
de leur exploitation,
ils ont besoin
d'un accompagnement d'urgence
pour la casse et les pertes.
Qui sera concerné
par l'état de catastrophe?
Sous quelles conditions?
Quels délais?
Les Finistériens
attendent
de votre part
une réponse claire
et précise.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran.
- Olivier Véran:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Merci pour votre question,
madame
la députée.
Vous l'avez souligné,
cette tempête
qui a balayé le nord-ouest
de la France n'a rien d'ordinaire.
Il y a eu trois fois
plus de foyers privés
d'électricité
dans le Finistère
que lors de la précédente
tempête
de 1999.
Cela a été dit
par la présidente
de l'Assemblée
nationale,
nous avons eu trois morts,
et notamment
un agent d'Enedis.
Il y a des milliers
de pompiers
qui ont été déployés
sur le territoire concerné.
Plus de 11.000 interventions
ont été réalisées.
Des milliers d'interventions
ont été réalisées
par les salariés d'Enedis.
Je veux saluer
le dispositif d'alerte
qui a pu être mis en place
pour la première fois
dans notre pays.
Il a permis à 98%
de la population concernée
d'être alertée
sur les risques liés
à la tempête
et sur les manières
de se protéger.
Sans cela, le bilan
humain aurait été
plus important.
Vous soulignez
les pertes
qu'il y a sur les exploitations
agricoles.
Je vous redis ce qu'a
dit le président
de la République,
parce que c'est
ce qu'il va se passer:
toutes les communes
qui relèvent de l'état
de catastrophe naturelle seront
reconnues comme telles.
Il y aura une réunion
le 14 novembre.
Dans les jours qui suivront,
un décret sera pris.
Tout ce qui a été
annoncé par le chef
de l'Etat et par la Première
ministre, s'agissant
des agriculteurs,
ils recevront
tout le soutien
des assureurs
et de l'Etat partout
où ce sera nécessaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Mélanie Thomin:
Quand on a tout perdu,
rien ne serait pire
qu'un espoir déçu.
Il y a urgence
à indemniser l'ensemble
des secteurs agricoles touchés.
En dépit des annonces
présidentielles,
tous ces acteurs
se retrouvent seuls face
à l'assureur.
Je voulais
le dire,
n'oublions pas les foyers
qui restent
encore aujourd'hui
sans électricité.
Je veux saluer
l'esprit de solidarité
qui a surgi au coeur de la crise.
Les professionnels
d'Enedis
et leurs sous-traitants
sont sur le pont
au péril de leur vie.
Vous avez évoqué
l'agent décédé,
il est un héros du service public.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Erwan Balanant
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Erwan Balanant:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la Première
ministre,
dans le Finistère,
nous avons connu
des tempêtes.
Pour tous,
celle qui vient de dévaster
la pointe de la Bretagne
avait un nom,
la tempête Ciaran.
Pour nous, il restera
un autre prénom,
un autre nom et un autre
visage associé
à cette tempête,
celui de l'agent d'Enedis décédé
en travaillant à rétablir
l'électricité.
Il avait 46 ans et trois enfants.
Applaudissements
Originaire d'Auch,
il venait
dans le cadre de la force
d'intervention rapide
comme de nombreux
agents d'Enedis
pour rétablir le réseau
électrique dévasté.
En mon nom et au nom
des habitants
de ma circonscription,
je souhaite
lui rendre hommage.
Son sens du devoir nous honore.
Je veux remercier
et féliciter le préfet
du Finistère.
Tous les élus,
les pompiers, les forces
de l'ordre
et les citoyens
ont fait preuve d'une
solidarité incroyable.
Si cette crise
a été anticipée
et bien gérée,
elle nous interroge.
Nous savons
que le dérèglement climatique
ne va qu'accentuer
ces catastrophes.
Nous sommes devenus dépendants
aux télécommunications.
La coupure totale
de tous les réseaux
a été particulièrement
mal vécue par tous.
Il est primordial
d'en tirer les leçons
pour améliorer
notre anticipation
et protéger la population.
Dans la continuité
du déplacement
de Jean-Noël Barrot hier,
je souhaite m'adresser
à madame la Première ministre.
Comment l'Etat
compte-t-il améliorer
son plan de crise
pour améliorer
la résilience des réseaux
et leur capacité
à rester opérationnels?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
je voudrais
à mon tour exprimer
toute ma solidarité
et mon soutien
aux victimes,
à leurs familles
et à leurs proches.
J'ai également
une pensée
pour tous ceux
de nos concitoyens
dont les biens ont subi
des dégâts considérables.
Vous l'avez dit,
le bilan est lourd.
Il aurait pu être dramatique.
Si nous avons pu faire face
à ces épisodes climatiques
exceptionnels, c'est grâce
au dispositif d'alerte,
au dispositif
de prévention et également
à la responsabilité
de nos concitoyens.
C'est grâce également
à la mobilisation exceptionnelle
de nos sapeurs-pompiers,
des équipes
de secours,
des collectivités
qui sont intervenues,
y compris
au plus fort de la tempête,
pour venir
en aide à nos concitoyens.
Je veux, à nouveau,
leur rendre hommage.
Vous l'avez dit,
ces tempêtes
et ces dérèglements
climatiques,
on sait
qu'ils vont être amenés
à se reproduire.
Si nos opérateurs
de réseaux ont été
très mobilisés
ces derniers jours,
y compris s'agissant
d'Enedis, au prix
de la vie
d'un des agents
qui était intervenu
en Bretagne,
nous devons effectivement
mieux anticiper
ces tempêtes et nous préparer
à faire face
à des vents
violents,
comme nous les avons connus
ces derniers jours,
et aussi à des inondations.
J'ai une pensée
pour tous les habitants
du Pas-de-Calais
qui vivent actuellement
des inondations exceptionnelles.
Le ministre
de la Transition écologique
s'y rendra demain
et il pourra rencontrer
les élus et nos concitoyens
qui vivent
ces inondations.
Tous ces dérèglements
climatiques doivent
nous amener à anticiper,
à préparer
et à améliorer
la résilience
de nos réseaux.
C'est tout le sens du plan
national d'adaptation
au changement
climatique sur lequel
le ministre de la Transition
écologique travaille actuellement,
en lien avec les collectivités.
Nous sommes aux côtés
de nos concitoyens
qui vivent aujourd'hui
ces dérèglements climatiques.
Nous travaillons
pour mieux anticiper
et éviter demain
d'avoir de nouvelles difficultés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la Première ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Eric Coquerel,
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Eric Coquerel:
Madame la Première ministre,
depuis le 7 octobre,
163 Palestiniens
ont été tués en Cisjordanie,
où le Hamas
ne se trouve pas.
La violence se renforce.
A Gaza, si l'on reprend
les chiffres
de l'ONU, on compte plus de 10.000
Palestiniens tués,
dont de nombreux enfants.
La disproportion
entre le nombre
de civils tués
et le nombre de membres
du Hamas tués
prouve
que ce ne sont pas juste
des victimes collatérales
involontaires.
Les civils palestiniens
sont directement ciblés.
La politique coloniale
accrue en Cisjordanie
et le nettoyage
ethnique en cours
à Gaza répondent
à l'objectif présenté
par Benyamin Netanyahou à l'ONU.
Il assume qu'Israël prendra
la responsabilité générale
de la sécurité à Gaza.
Cette entreprise
ne répond pas
à un prétendu choc
de civilisation.
Cette guerre est géopolitique.
Ne la transformons pas ici
en guerre
de religion.
Ceci doit être combattu
comme l'islamophobie
et le racisme.
Lors du débat parlementaire
du 23 octobre,
vous sembliez
engager la France
dans cette voie:
trêve humanitaire entraînant
à un cessez-le-feu,
plan de paix
sur la base d'une
solution à deux Etats.
Depuis, le terme même
de cessez-le-feu
a quasiment disparu
de votre communication officielle.
Nous sommes des millions
à le demander.
Quelle est la feuille
de route
de la France
pour s'imposer
en tant que voix pour la paix?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à madame
Chrysoula Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou:
Madame
la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs,
la France est fortement
préoccupée
par la situation
à Gaza, notamment
par l'urgence humanitaire à Gaza.
Comme l'a souligné
la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères ce dimanche,
nous appelons sans ambiguïté
à une trêve humanitaire immédiate.
Cette position
ferme et claire,
nous la tenons à l'ONU
dans l'assemblée générale,
avec l'adoption
de la résolution jordanienne.
Le président
de la République organise
ce jeudi à Paris une conférence
humanitaire internationale
pour la population
civile de Gaza
autour de trois piliers:
le respect
du droit international
humanitaire
sur la protection des civils,
une réponse humanitaire
dans le secteur
de la santé, et un appel
à la mobilisation
concrète en faveur
des civils de Gaza.
Rien dans la lutte
antiterroriste
ne nous autorise
à se soustraire
au droit international.
Protéger les civils
est une obligation stricte.
Chaque civil qui meurt
lors d'une frappe
à Gaza est une vie perdue
et c'est insupportable.
L'emploi de lieux
civils par le Hamas
est aussi une infraction
au droit international
qui doit être condamné.
Nous condamnons
les exactions des colons
qui se multiplient.
Israël doit faire
cesser ces violences
avec détermination.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Bertrand Sorre,
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Bertrand Sorre:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Dans la nuit du mercredi
1er au 2 novembre,
la tempête Ciaran
a balayé notre pays.
Les habitants
de nos départements
ont vécu des heures d'angoisse.
Le bilan humain
est lourd
avec trois personnes
décédées et 47 blessés,
dont de nombreux pompiers.
Je souhaite rendre
hommage à mon tour
à cet employé
d'Enedis qui a trouvé
la mort
alors qu'il travaillait
pour rétablir
l'alimentation électrique
dans le Finistère.
Mes pensées, comme celles
de la représentation
internationale, s'adressent
à sa famille et à ses proches.
Les sapeurs-pompiers,
les forces
de l'ordre, les gendarmes
et policiers,
les maires
et les élus locaux
sont tous mobilisés
pour alerter
et pour gérer les situations
de crise créées
par ces intempéries majeures.
Sans cette anticipation
d'ampleur
et cet engagement de tous,
le bilan humain aurait été
plus dramatique.
Le bilan matériel
est considérable:
arbres déracinés
tombés sur des maisons
ou des voitures,
vitres brisées,
toitures envolées...
Les assureurs font état
de plus de 300.000 déclarations
de sinistres.
Le président
de la République a tenu
à rencontrer
des personnes sinistrées
pour leur apporter son soutien.
Il leur a permis
l'activation rapide
de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
et celui de l'état
de calamité agricole.
Cela permet l'indemnisation
des victimes.
Alors qu'un
nombre important
de nos concitoyens sont toujours
privés d'électricité,
pouvez-vous
nous confirmer
que tous
les départements touchés
par la tempête Ciaran
seront bien concernés
par ces deux mesures?
Pouvez-vous éclairer
l'Assemblée
sur la date de publication
des décrets?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
vous avez rappelé
que la Manche avait été
fortement touchée
par la tempête Ciaran,
comme l'Europe.
Notre collègue a rappelé
que le Finistère
avait aussi été touché.
Les services de l'Etat ont été
présents massivement.
20.000 pompiers,
13.000 interventions:
après le déclenchement
du dispositif
de catastrophe
naturelle, on a pris
la dimension
de ce véritable drame.
Il y a eu trois décès.
Heureusement qu'il y a eu
le système d'alerte mis
en place par le ministère
de l'Intérieur,
qui a permis
de prévenir par SMS
tous ceux qui étaient
dans des situations
de fragilité.
La question
que vous posez est simple
et claire.
Nous avons pris
la décision de placer
en situation
de catastrophe naturelle
tous les départements
qui ont été touchés.
A la réunion
du 14 novembre prochain,
nous allons constituer
des dossiers.
Certains ont tout perdu.
Ils ont perdu leur activité
professionnelle
pour de longs mois.
Il appartient
aux assureurs de faire
des diagnostics
dans les meilleurs délais.
Le fonds de calamité
agricole a été activé,
de même que le système
assurantiel
qui a été mis en place
par le gouvernement.
Les agriculteurs
ne seront pas oubliés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Philippe Tanguy,
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Jean-Philippe Tanguy:
Madame la Première ministre,
contre ma volonté,
j'ai été le témoin
de la plus effroyable
défaite
de la raison
et du plus sauvage triomphe
de la brutalité.
"Jamais une génération
n'est tombée
dans une telle décadence morale."
Quand il écrit ces mots,
Stefan Zweig fuit
la barbarie et la haine
antisémite.
Il ne survivra pas
à une civilisation
qu'il savait défigurée.
Une civilisation
qui est la part
de l'homme que les camps
ont voulu détruire,
comme le disait Malraux.
Le soutien indéfectible
qu'aurait dû subir Israël
est meurtri par un effroyable
relativisme
et une ignoble flambée
d'antisémitisme.
Pire encore, l'hydre
odieuse de la haine
des Juifs
ne vient pas s'écraser
contre un mur
unanime de bouclier
et de glaives
de notre démocratie
pour l'abattre,
mais elle se fraie
un chemin à travers
notre République.
Sa source essentielle,
sa source cardinale
est désormais l'islamisme.
L'islamisme que les nations
ont laissé s'infiltrer
jaillit à nos visages.
Dans nos rues,
dans nos écoles,
au sein des médias,
des sports
et de la culture,
la haine du Juif
est partout, de l'insulte
jusqu'au meurtre.
Qu'avons-nous fait
du devoir de mémoire?
Avons-nous oublié
que la barbarie attaque
les gens de bien?
Dans un tel moment,
aucune division n'est tolérable.
Il est temps
que la France
et la République revendiquent
leur civilisation!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran,
porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
l'antisémitisme
qui s'exprime
sur les frontons
de nos maisons,
sur les portes des immeubles,
dans les injures
qui peuvent être lancées
dans les rames de métro,
cet antisémitisme
qui fait
que nos concitoyens n'osent
plus faire leurs courses
normalement, n'osent
plus prendre les transports
en commun normalement,
c'est un fléau
que nous condamnons
tous et que nous devons
combattre
avec acharnement.
Il est autant une hérésie
temporelle qu'un anachronisme.
Cet antisémitisme,
il n'est pas né
au lendemain du 7 octobre.
Il y avait un antisémitisme
insidieux, parfois révélé
à travers des actes antisémites.
La France déplorait déjà plusieurs
centaines d'actes
de cette nature chaque année.
Cet antisémitisme,
il croit désormais
qu'il serait
légitime à exploser
au grand jour,
comme légitimé
par le conflit
israélo-palestinien,
qui permettrait
à ceux qui ont toujours haï
les Juifs
de pouvoir le faire
dans la sphère publique.
Nous combattons tous
cet antisémitisme
dans cet hémicycle.
Je ne peux imaginer
qu'un député
de la nation ne puisse combattre
l'antisémitisme.
Je le dirai ici
sans polémique,
vous pointez l'extrême
gauche, je vais
vous pointer vous.
Vous êtes le parti de la flamme.
Il n'y a pas un bon
et un mauvais antisémitisme.
Le président
de votre groupe a refusé
de reconnaître
que le fondateur
de votre parti a été condamné
pour antisémitisme!
Soyons tous unis
une fois
pour tous
contre l'antisémitisme,
sans réserve,
dans tous les bords
de l'hémicycle!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur le ministre.
Je vous remercie.
Un peu de silence,
s'il vous plaît.
La parole est à madame Marie-Agnès
Poussier-Winsback.
- Marie-Agnès
Poussier-Winsback:
Madame la présidente,
chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de la Transition
écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Une grande partie
du littoral français
a subi coup sur coup
deux tempêtes
de grande ampleur.
Aujourd'hui,
ce sont encore des inondations
et des crues qui sont à gérer.
Nous avons appris
que deux personnes
étaient décédées,
47 personnes
avaient été blessées
et qu'un agent d'Enedis
avait trouvé la mort
lors d'une intervention.
J'adresse toutes nos condoléances
à leurs proches.
Malgré ce contexte
et grâce à une information
importante
et une anticipation
sans précédent,
nous avons pu anticiper
une catastrophe plus importante.
Je voudrais rendre
hommage à tous
ces hommes et ces femmes
qui ont été
et sont encore
sur le terrain,
pour permettre
à nos concitoyens
d'avoir de l'eau,
de l'électricité, un toit.
Je remercie également les élus
des communes rurales.
Ils utilisent souvent
leur matériel personnel
pour déblayer.
Les dégâts sont colossaux:
des toitures envolées,
des bâtiments effondrés,
des arbres tombés
sur des bâtiments, des exploitations
agricoles dévastées.
Le montant des indemnisations
devrait être important.
Ce qui inquiète
les collectivités,
ce sont les montants
des primes
qui leur sont demandées
pour s'assurer.
Certains assureurs se désengagent.
Vous le savez, les tarifs
et les franchises s'envolent.
Vous aviez confié
une mission
sur ce sujet.
Il va falloir trouver
des solutions
très vite.
Les maires
ne rempileront pas
dans ces conditions.
Ils seront obligés
de devenir
leurs propres assureurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la députée
Poussier-Winsback,
je ne reviens
pas sur ce que vous avez dit.
Je me joins à votre hommage.
J'insiste sur le fait
que nous connaissons
en ce moment
des crues
qui sont à des niveaux
historiques,
en particulier
dans le Pas-de-Calais.
Les consignes
de prudence doivent
être répétées.
Les conditions
météo
n'annoncent pas
d'amélioration
pour les prochains jours.
J'aurai l'occasion,
demain, de me rendre
sur place.
Vous parlez d'un cas,
celui de l'indemnisation
des dommages
par les collectivités.
D'abord, à hyper
court terme,
il y a une clause
dans les polices d'assurance
pour la tempête
que toutes les collectivités
et tous les particuliers
doivent faire jouer,
indépendamment de ce que l'Etat
pourra décider.
Ensuite, il y a un fonds
de solidarité.
C'est la fusion
d'une dotation
pour les collectivités
touchées
par des catastrophes naturelles
et d'une dotation
pour les collectivités
touchées
par une calamité publique.
Ces fonds permettent d'aider
les infrastructures,
les parcs et jardins,
de bénéficier
de crédits pour les reconstruire.
Le sujet
qui est devant nous,
c'est l'accélération
de ces catastrophes naturelles,
à cause du réchauffement
climatique.
Il y aura une mission
conjointe pilotée
par Bercy qui concerne
aussi bien l'érosion
du trait de côte
que la multiplication
des vagues-submersion.
A l'intérieur de cela,
compte tenu
du nombre de communes
qui saturent,
un maire et un assureur
devront rendre
une mission
avec des préconisations
pour faire en sorte
de concevoir
un nouveau dispositif
de soutien
pour les collectivités.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre du Logement.
Après cinq ans
pour vous convaincre,
vous avez enfin pris
de bonnes résolutions.
Vous abordez la rénovation
des logements
dans une approche globale.
MaPrimeRénov' est donc utilisée.
Vous atteignez
vos objectifs en passant
de 70.000 à plus de 200.000
rénovations complètes.
On est encore loin
des objectifs
du Haut Conseil
pour le climat,
qui préconise
370.000 rénovations
par an, mais la volonté est là.
Vous annonciez 1,6 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires
pour financer
MaPrimeRénov', notamment
pour les plus modestes.
Jusque-là, tout va bien.
Mais quand arrive
l'examen budgétaire,
les choses se gâtent.
Les crédits dédiés
à ces questions
ne sont pas suffisants.
Vous nous avez indiqué
que les fonds viendraient
des recettes de quotas carbone.
Mais nous les avions déjà en 2022.
Ce ne sont pas des crédits
supplémentaires,
comme annoncé.
Où sont les 700
millions qui manquent
à votre parole?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à...
Monsieur Patrice Vergriete.
- Patrice Vergriete:
Monsieur le député Bricout,
c'est un effort
sans précédent
qui est engagé
par le gouvernement
pour 2024, avec 5 milliards
d'euros envisagés
pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements.
Je vous le confirme.
C'est bien une hausse de 1,6
milliard d'euros
par rapport à 2023.
Les 700 millions
que vous évoquiez,
pour les quotas
carbone, sont bien
dans le projet de loi de finances.
Il y a également le reliquat
de la trésorerie
de l'Agence nationale
de l'amélioration
de l'habitat,
qui permettra
à cette dernière de doter 4,6
milliards d'euros
pour la rénovation énergétique
des logements en 2024.
Vous le savez,
je l'ai déjà évoqué,
les 400.000 euros qui restent
viendront aider l'amélioration
du parc de logement social.
Au total, on aura bien 5
milliards d'euros
pour 2024.
Par rapport
à ce que vous avez évoqué
sur la rénovation
globale, c'est vrai
que jusqu'à présent,
MaPrimeRénov'
a essentiellement
privilégié du mono-geste.
Le tournant
que nous prenons,
avec les accompagnateurs
qui permettront d'accompagner
les propriétaires
dans la rénovation
de leur logement,
c'est de monter
cette ambition.
Vous avez parlé de 200.000
rénovations globales
envisagées pour 2024.
On n'est pas
encore à 360.000,
mais c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction.
Je vous confirme les 5
milliards d'euros prévus
pour 2024.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Bricout?
- Jean-Louis Bricout:
Merci
pour votre réponse.
Les quotas carbone
ne sont pas des recettes
supplémentaires.
Les flous budgétaires
mériteraient quelquefois
une réponse plus précise.
On a besoin de ces 700
millions d'euros
pour rénover
nos logements,
pour des enjeux
écologiques, sociaux
et pour notre économie
locale de proximité.
Le 49.3 va nous priver
de débat budgétaire.
Ne nous privez pas
de ces crédits
et inscrivez ces 700
millions d'euros
au budget.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Céline Calvez.
- Céline Calvez: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à Gabriel Attal.
Depuis votre prise
de fonction,
vous avez fait
de la lutte
contre le harcèlement
scolaire
une des priorités de votre action.
Votre engagement total
a permis la libération
de témoignages.
Ces témoignages, nous les avons
parfois retrouvés et découverts.
Il faut témoigner
des tourments incessants,
de leur prolongement
dans l'espace numérique,
témoigner pour mieux dire
stop au harcèlement,
témoigner
parce qu'on est victime
ou parce qu'on l'a été,
témoigner aussi
parce qu'on a harcelé,
parfois
sans le vouloir ou le savoir.
Il faut
témoigner
parce qu'on est tous
témoins du harcèlement
sur d'autres personnes.
Il faut détecter
la situation pour mieux
la régler.
Le harcèlement
n'implique pas seulement
une relation
entre un auteur
et une victime.
Dorénavant, personne
ne doit être seul face
au harcèlement.
Il implique
toute la communauté éducative,
toute la communauté nationale.
Vous avez invité
toute notre communauté
à se mobiliser.
Dans deux jours,
c'est la journée nationale
de lutte
contre le harcèlement
dans tous les établissements
scolaires de France.
Vous aviez évoqué
des heures banalisées
pour permettre d'échanger.
Vous aviez parlé
d'un questionnaire
d'autoévaluation
pour mieux noter
ces situations à l'école.
Pouvez-vous
nous préciser comment
va se dérouler cette journée?
Au-delà
de cette journée,
parce que je connais
votre attachement
à ce sujet,
que prévoyez-vous auprès
des élèves,
des enseignants et auprès
des parents?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la députée Céline Calvez,
vous l'avez dit,
cette semaine
est une semaine décisive
dans le combat
que nous menons
contre le harcèlement,
qui s'est concrétisé
par le plan
que la Première ministre
a présenté
il y a plusieurs semaines.
Chaque année,
il y a une journée nationale
de lutte contre le harcèlement.
En général,
elle se tient
autour d'un tiers
des établissements
qui organisent des actions
autour du harcèlement.
Cette année,
nous voulons
qu'elle soit plus large.
Les cours
vont s'arrêter
pendant deux heures
dans toutes les classes
de France
pour avoir un temps dédié
à la lutte contre le harcèlement.
Les équipes éducatives,
avec les élèves,
vont échanger sur le harcèlement.
Tous les élèves
se verront proposer
un outil d'autoévaluation
du harcèlement.
On a construit
ce questionnaire
avec des spécialistes
de la santé mentale,
de l'enfant, du climat scolaire.
Nous avons fait appel
à de nombreux spécialistes.
On se rend compte
que des élèves
qui peuvent subir le harcèlement
finissent parfois
par élever leur seuil
de tolérance
et accepter
des choses
qui ne peuvent pas l'être.
Ce questionnaire
va permettre probablement
de libérer encore davantage
la parole.
Il nous permettra
d'avoir des données actualisées
au niveau national.
Les dernières
données
que nous avons sur le harcèlement
datent
de 2011.
TikTok et Snapchat
n'existaient pas.
Nous allons
continuer pour aller
plus loin.
Nous allons développer
un temps dédié
à l'apprentissage
de l'autre,
dans toutes les écoles
primaires,
dès la rentrée prochaine.
Pour les parents,
en janvier 2024,
un module numérique
pour les accompagner
dans le repérage
des signaux faibles
du harcèlement
à la maison verra
le jour.
On continue à se mobiliser.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Cyrielle Chatelain.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Merci.
Laissez-moi
vous citer:
"En tant que garde des Sceaux,
Eric Dupond-Moretti
a toute ma confiance et fait
un excellent travail."
Telle
était votre déclaration
hier sur France Inter.
C'est difficile
pour vous d'admettre qu'une
nouvelle affaire touche
votre gouvernement.
Le ministre de la Justice
est poursuivi
par sa propre justice.
C'est une plaisanterie,
à part
dans une République
où on a Emmanuel Macron
comme président.
Félicitations!
Continuez de congratuler
votre garde
des Sceaux
pour son excellent travail,
qui est soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé
son ministère
et les services
qui en dépendent
pour régler ses comptes.
Depuis juillet 2021,
il est obsédé
par sa défense.
Il a fait un recours
devant le Conseil constitutionnel,
huit pourvois en cassation.
Cela signifie des heures
de jurisprudence,
des rendez-vous
avec ses avocats,
des heures
où il n'est pas ministre.
Pendant 15 jours,
ce garde des Sceaux sera empêché
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions.
Il ne s'autorise
non pas un,
mais deux bras d'honneur
dans cet hémicycle
parce qu'un président
ose évoquer
la procédure qui le concerne.
Ce garde des Sceaux
se pose en victime.
Madame la Première ministre,
un ministre mis
en examen doit
démissionner,
selon la procédure Balladur.
Ma question
est simple:
qu'est-ce que ça fait,
depuis mai 2022,
de diriger un gouvernement
sans garde
des Sceaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Madame la présidente Chatelain,
il y a dans notre Etat de droit
un principe auquel
je tiens.
C'est la présomption d'innocence.
J'imagine,
madame Chatelain,
que vous y êtes aussi attachée.
Le ministre de la Justice,
comme tous,
y a droit.
Le procès s'est ouvert hier
et il durera jusqu'au 16 novembre.
Sur une procédure en cours,
je ne vais faire
aucun commentaire.
Pendant cette période,
des mesures pratiques,
classiques, d'organisation
ont été prises.
La continuité de l'Etat
et de l'action gouvernementale
est assurée.
Comme garde des Sceaux,
Eric Dupond-Moretti
a toute ma confiance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Madame la présidente?
- Cyrielle Chatelain:
Comme tous, ici,
nous sommes attachés
à la présomption d'innocence.
Ce gouvernement est-il
attaché au principe de probité?
Apparemment, non.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Josiane Corneloup.
- Josiane Corneloup:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Agriculture.
Les attaques du loup
se multiplient.
J'étais déjà
intervenue
il y a trois ans
pour alerter le gouvernement
sur l'impossible
cohabitation
dans le bocage charolais
de ce prédateur
avec un mode pastoral
traditionnel.
La surprotection
dont bénéficie aujourd'hui
le loup entraîne
sa prolifération
et désespère les éleveurs.
Les actes de prédation
se multiplient.
Des chevaux
ont été
il y a quelques jours
victimes du loup,
en Saône-et-Loire.
Une pouliche de 18 mois,
agonisante,
a dû être euthanasiée.
C'est un drame.
Pour ce couple d'éleveurs
qui a travaillé jour
et nuit afin de faire
de son haras
le plus important
des haras privés
de Bourgogne,
c'est un désastre.
Cette pouliche
était issue d'une
très belle souche.
Les éleveurs craignent
que certains propriétaires
ne veuillent plus mettre
leurs chevaux
en pension chez eux.
Le sort des éleveurs
est en danger.
Ce n'est pas une aide
psychologique
dont ont besoin
les éleveurs,
mais de mesures
fortes qui témoignent
du soutien de l'Etat
au monde agricole.
Il s'agit
de plus en plus d'un fléau.
Allez-vous instaurer
une indispensable procédure
d'abattage rapide,
sans passer par l'étape
de la gradation
des tirs,
comme cela se fait
déjà en Autriche
et en Suisse?
Allez-vous permettre
aux éleveurs
de retrouver la sécurité
et la sérénité?
Allez-vous écouter la voix
des territoires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau:
Madame la députée
Josiane Corneloup,
ce n'est pas principalement
un préjudice économique
que subissent
les éleveurs.
Ils ont peur
de ne pas pouvoir poursuivre
leur activité.
Dans votre département,
le loup
est réapparu depuis 2019.
Les attaques se sont multipliées.
215 animaux ont été
tués par des loups
cette année.
Sur le plan loup
actuel,
nous avons décidé de renforcer
les moyens présents
sur le territoire,
en particulier
la brigade loup
qui va être présente
pour faire en sorte
que les tirs prévus puissent
être faits.
Dans les zones
de colonisation,
on a des sujets
de professionnalisation.
On a besoin de formation.
Les brigades loup
sont là pour cela.
Deuxième élément
sur le plan loup,
on essaie de tenir
une position d'équilibre.
Nous avons travaillé
avec le ministère
de l'Ecologie sur ce sujet.
Il y a un effectif
à partir duquel
on peut se poser
la question du statut
du loup.
Ensuite, il y a la question
de la non-protection
d'un certain nombre de troupeaux.
Enfin, la prise en charge
des pertes indirectes.
Pour l'instant,
il n'y
avait que les pertes
directes
qui étaient concernées.
Nous avons soumis
à la consultation
le plan loup,
qui permettra de trouver
des perspectives
plus sereines
pour les éleveurs
et les agriculteurs
qui souffrent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Caroline Fiat.
- Caroline Fiat: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, hier,
j'ai lu sur les réseaux
sociaux:
"Les femmes travaillent désormais
gratuitement jusqu'à
la fin de l'année.
Mixité des métiers,
accès aux postes
à responsabilité,
égalité salariale,
nous devons agir
sur tous les leviers
et j'y veillerai."
Je me suis dit: "Quel programme!
Quelle ambition!"
Quand j'ai vu que c'était
vous,
je me suis dit
que c'était hypocrite.
87% des aides-soignants
sont des femmes.
Vous espérez
que cela change
par la formation professionnelle.
Près de 90%
de femmes
sont dans les filières
sanitaires
et sociales et sont les plus mal
rémunérées.
Pour l'accès aux postes
à responsabilité,
vous pourrez
vous satisfaire
d'être Première ministre.
Pendant l'examen
du PLFSS en commission,
nous avons fait
des propositions
pour aboutir
à l'égalité salariale.
Résultat: rien.
Les écarts de salaires
entre les femmes
et les hommes ne se réduisent
quasiment pas.
Si le rythme actuel
est maintenu,
les femmes devraient
gagner autant
que les hommes d'ici 2234.
Quel sens des priorités!
Nous proposons que l'accès
aux subventions publiques
soit réservé aux structures
respectant strictement
l'égalité salariale.
Pourtant, vos députés
ont voté contre.
Vous êtes obnubilée par ça.
Vous oubliez l'essentiel:
les propositions
de vos oppositions.
Comptez-vous agir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt:
Nous pouvons
nous retrouver
sur un premier constat,
le fait que les inégalités
salariales
sont inacceptables.
Le principe
d'égalité salariale
qui a été posé
en 1972 porte
encore des difficultés.
Il n'est pas parfaitement
respecté.
Sur les inégalités
de salaire
que nous avons expliquées,
une partie relève
de discrimination,
de culture
de la discrimination
entre femmes
et hommes.
Que faire?
D'abord, conforter
ce que nous faisons déjà.
Depuis 2019,
nous avons un index
qui mesure les inégalités
professionnelles.
Nous avons voté
en 2021 une loi
sur l'accès des femmes
aux responsabilités
dans les grandes entreprises.
Il faut aller plus loin.
Il faut passer
par les chantiers
que nous avons ouverts
lors de la conférence sociale.
Il faut lutter contre les temps
partiels subis.
Les temps
partiels subis
sont une des premières
explications
à cette grande
différence
entre le salaire
des hommes
et celui des femmes.
Il faut faire en sorte
que cet index
sur l'égalité
femmes-hommes
soit plus coercitif
et plus efficace.
Enfin, il faut
mettre en oeuvre
les dispositions
de la directive européenne
sur la transparence
et l'égalité salariale.
La France a jusqu'à 2026
pour faire cela.
Ce dispositif sera transposé
d'ici début 2025.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Caroline Fiat:
L'avantage d'être élus,
c'est que notre
indemnité
n'est pas pénalisée par l'inégalité
salariale femmes-hommes.
Nous ne sommes pas
bénévoles
depuis hier matin.
Vous auriez pu me répondre.
L'application de l'égalité
salariale permettrait
de financer les retraites
et permettrait
aux Français de partir
à la retraite à 60 ans!
Ambitieux, non?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Eric Poulliat.
- Eric Poulliat: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
dans quelques jours,
nous nous remémorerons
les attentats du 13 novembre 2015.
Le terrorisme
a choisi ses ennemis
et les désigne: les laïcs,
les intellectuels,
les femmes, les juifs et tous
les républicains
sont visés.
Cette idéologie
haineuse veut lutter
contre notre pays des Lumières.
Il frappe les symboles,
les visages,
nos soldats,
nos policiers et gendarmes
et nos enseignants.
Il a frappé
le coeur battant
de notre société récemment,
c'est-à-dire notre jeunesse.
L'islamisme n'a qu'un projet:
détruire notre démocratie.
Il n'a qu'un moyen:
radicaliser
les esprits
et les faire basculer
dans la violence et la terreur.
Depuis des décennies,
nous apprenons,
nous réagissons
et nous nous adaptons.
Aujourd'hui, face
aux actes antisémites
que subissent
nos compatriotes juifs,
aucune voix républicaine
ne peut manquer
dans ce combat.
Nous devons
nous battre
pour que nous puissions
vivre nos croyances
et convictions intimes.
Il faut
que les visages
de la République
ne se sentent
plus abandonnés, mais soutenus
et portés par un peuple.
Il faut que notre jeunesse
reprenne
le flambeau des Lumières.
Dans nos écoles
et nos universités,
dans nos services
publics, nos clubs
de sport, nous devons
nous battre
et refuser une société
des communautés.
Quelles sont vos actions
pour oeuvrer
à une riposte
partagée de lutte
contre l'islamisme,
pour qu'enfin
nous retrouvions
le chemin du commun,
celui d'un peuple
aux multiples facettes,
uni par une fraternité
et l'amour
de la République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la ministre
en charge
de la Citoyenneté et de la Ville.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Je partage entièrement
votre analyse
sur ce travail
de l'islamisme radical
qui se déploie
dans toutes les sphères
de la société,
dans le tissu associatif,
ou encore à l'école
de la République.
Le président
a appelé à défendre
les valeurs
de la République,
de notre République,
à nous opposer
au repli communautaire.
Le gouvernement a déployé
une stratégie globale
de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamiste.
Il veut amplifier
l'ensemble des actions
pour l'égalité
des chances
sur tous les territoires
et accompagner
la structuration
du culte musulman
dans notre pays,
face aux dérives
de l'islamisme.
Une loi a été votée
le 24 août 2021.
Près de 30.000
opérations de contrôle
ont été faites par les services.
1072 établissements
séparatistes
ont été fermés
à titre temporaire
ou définitif.
780 signalements
ont été faits
par les préfets.
949 étrangers radicalisés
ont été expulsés
ou maintenus hors du territoire.
Face à l'islamisme radical,
le gouvernement est mobilisé.
Vous pouvez compter
sur toute ma détermination,
je vous le dis,
pour lutter
contre toutes les atteintes
à nos valeurs
et à nos principes fondamentaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Frédéric Maillot.
- Frédéric Maillot:
Madame la présidente,
mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à madame Olivia Grégoire.
C'est un cri
d'alerte en Hexagone
et chez moi,
à La Réunion, où les TPE
et PME représentent 95%
de notre économie.
Ces entreprises
sont en souffrance.
Ce sont des carreleurs,
des boulangers
et des charcutiers
qui se lèvent
chaque matin pour faire tourner
l'économie réunionnaise.
Ce sont les premiers
employeurs de l'île.
Ils croulent
sous les charges sociales
et ils n'ont
plus les moyens de venir
à bout de leurs charges.
Si nous ne faisons rien,
ce sont 15.000 entreprises
qui risquent
la fermeture,
avec ses conséquences
néfastes sur l'emploi
dans un territoire
qui compte déjà 18%
de chômage.
Vous avez aidé les géants
de l'économie réunionnaise,
et maintenant, les TPE
et PME attendent
le même soutien.
Vous avez aidé Goliath,
il faut maintenant aider David.
Les agences
de l'inspection générale
des finances
prévoient de supprimer
des mécanismes
de défiscalisation destinés
aux sociétés ultramarines.
C'est un nouveau
coup bas porté
à nos entreprises locales.
Je sais pouvoir
compter
sur vous quand il s'agit
de défendre l'économie.
Il faut échelonner,
voire supprimer,
réadapter le système de calcul
de l'économie insulaire.
Voilà la solution
que je vous demande
de considérer.
Etes-vous prête à écouter
ce cri d'alarme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
je voulais
vous dire qu'avec
Olivia Grégoire,
on soutient
depuis longtemps les PME
et les TPE.
Ce sont elles
qui fournissent
le plus d'emplois,
et en particulier
dans le département
que vous représentez, La Réunion.
Si 2022
est une très belle année
pour la création d'emplois
dans le tourisme,
pour 2023, c'est difficile.
Vous le savez, vous avez été
très présent hier soir
sur les débats sur l'outre-mer.
Je vous rappelle
qu'il y a des exonérations
de charges
qui sont amplifiées en 2024.
Dans les zones
franches,
il y a des nouveaux
secteurs d'activité
et des systèmes
de défiscalisation
qui vont intervenir.
Nous travaillons
sur la vie chère
avec la réforme sur les outre-mer.
Nous avons lancé
une mission
sur les autres pôles
pour faire en sorte
que les TPE et les PME soient
mieux protégées.
Nous travaillons
sur quelque chose
de très important.
Nous allons aboutir
sur la fameuse norme
qui va remplacer la norme CE.
Cela fait 20 ans
que l'on attend
cette réforme.
Au mois de mars
2024, nous serons
au bout du chemin.
Nous allons y arriver.
Il y aura un effort
également
pour la formation.
Nous allons augmenter
de 30% les crédits
de mobilité pour 2024.
Sur l'innovation,
La Réunion
est une terre d'innovation.
J'étais
il y a quelques semaines
dans votre département.
J'ai vu
qu'il y avait des start-up
très innovantes.
Comptez sur moi
pour les soutenir
plus encore.
Cela montre le dynamisme
et le rayonnement
de l'économie ultramarine,
qui mérite d'être soutenue.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Laurent Jacobelli,
pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Laurent Jacobelli:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de la Culture.
"En ce moment,
il y a le déguisement
de Benyamin
Netanyahou,
ça marche pas mal,
un nazi
mais sans prépuce."
Où avons-nous entendu ces propos?
C'était sur France
Inter, une radio
du service
français
dont vous avez la tutelle.
De nombreux actes
antisémites ont été commis
en France et c'est le moment qu'a
choisi Guillaume Meurice
pour faire ce commentaire
antisémite.
Madame la ministre, vous semblez
y assister impuissante.
Comment pouvez-vous
tolérer
que les impôts
des Français servent
à financer l'antisémitisme
dans l'audiovisuel public,
après avoir financé le wokisme
et l'islamogauchisme?
Le comédien a écopé
d'un simple avertissement.
Ce n'est pas à la hauteur
du mal
qui ronge notre société.
Votre mutisme non plus.
Vous n'avez rien dit
pour condamner l'emploi
de journalistes
antisémites sur France 24,
ni même quand l'AFP
a refusé d'appeler
le Hamas un groupe terroriste.
Quand allez-vous prendre
des mesures concrètes
pour lutter contre cet
antisémitisme?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Rima Abdul Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je rappelle, n'en déplaise
au Rassemblement National,
que la presse
est totalement libre
dans notre pays.
Que s'est-il passé
dans ce cas précis?
Ne réduisez pas trois mots
d'un animateur humoriste
à l'ensemble de la politique
de l'audiovisuel
qui est menée
sous la houlette
de la présidente de la radio.
Elle s'est dite
profondément navrée.
Elle a rappelé
que l'antisémitisme
était une abomination
qui n'avait
pas sa place
dans leur organisation.
Adèle van Reeth
a rappelé que la limite
avait été franchie.
La présidente
de Radio France a envoyé
un message à l'ensemble
des équipes
de Radio France
pour rappeler les exigences
de rigueur et de modération.
L'Arcom a été saisie.
L'audiovisuel est régulé
par une autorité indépendante
dans notre pays,
pas par un politique,
dans un Etat de droit.
Ce n'est pas à la ministre
de la Culture
de choisir les animateurs
ni de contrôler
leurs propos.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame la ministre.
- Laurent Jacobelli:
Vous avez l'indignation sélective.
Vous étiez plus loquace
pour condamner
la nomination
d'un nouveau rédacteur
en chef d'un journal privé!
Vous étiez plus loquace
pour condamner
une chaîne d'information privée.
Vous étiez plus loquace
pour condamner
une émission
de divertissement
d'un groupe privé.
Comme par hasard,
lorsqu'il s'agit
de condamner l'antisémitisme
du service public,
il n'y a plus personne!
C'est votre responsabilité
et vous ne l'assumez pas!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur le député!
- Rima Abdul Malak: C'est vous
qui avez l'insulte sélective.
Vous pouvez reprendre
toutes mes interventions,
je n'ai jamais commenté
aucun animateur.
Je rappelle le cadre de la loi.
C'est à l'Arcom
de faire son travail
et de contrôler
les agissements
des chaînes privées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Un peu de silence.
La parole est à madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin.
- Marie-Charlotte Garin:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
en ce moment,
dans notre pays
qui se tient fermement
parmi les premières économies
du monde, une réalité sombre
et insupportable ébranle
nos consciences.
Des milliers d'appels au 115
sont sans réponse.
Des enfants
sont exposés au froid,
à l'insécurité et à la précarité.
A Lyon, des parents
d'élèves s'organisent
pour combler
l'espace
que vous n'arrivez pas à occuper,
faute
de moyens.
L'Abbé Pierre disait:
"Le contraire
de la misère
n'est pas la richesse,
c'est le partage."
Ce que nous voulons,
ce n'est pas
la charité.
Nous voulons du travail
et des logements dignes
pour tous.
Vous donnez des milliards
aux entreprises chaque année.
Vous baissez les aides
pour les personnes
qui ne sont déjà pas bien riches.
Vous êtes allé
jusqu'à criminaliser l'occupation
des logements vacants.
Le budget attribué à l'hébergement
d'urgence n'a jamais été aussi
haut parce que la situation n'a
jamais été aussi catastrophique.
Il y a 2800 enfants
qui dorment
dans les rues de notre pays.
Nous ne voulons pas
la charité,
mais il y a urgence.
La semaine dernière,
nous avons voté l'augmentation
des places
d'hébergement d'urgence
avec des députés de tous
bords politiques.
Ma question est simple.
Vous engagez-vous
à maintenir la création
de ces places
dans le budget final
que vous allez
faire adopter
malgré le 49.3?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Patrice Vergriete.
- Patrice Vergriete:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
aucun gouvernement
n'a créé autant
de places d'hébergement d'urgence.
Aucun gouvernement!
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à plus de 203.000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence.
Nous continuons
encore à les augmenter.
Avec le plan
logement, approuvé
par toutes les associations,
c'est 440.000 personnes
à la rue qui ont retrouvé
un logement.
Nous continuons
aujourd'hui ce travail.
Ce matin, j'ai eu l'occasion
d'annoncer 500 postes
supplémentaires,
un tiers des effectifs,
pour la veille sociale.
Le 115, que vous évoquez,
les maraudes
que vous évoquez aussi,
tout l'accompagnement social
pour permettre
à ces personnes,
non pas de dans l'hébergement
d'urgence,
parce que nous ne nous en
satisfaisons pas,
ça ne nous va pas!
Nous voulons trouver
des solutions
pour qu'ils puissent
trouver un logement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Une réponse?
- Marie-Charlotte Garin:
L'année dernière,
on a dû se battre
contre la suppression
de 14.000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence.
Nous savons
que ce n'est pas une baguette
magique, mais nous avons besoin
de solutions.
Pouvez-vous confirmer
que vous allez maintenir
la suppression de ces places?
C'est la réponse
que vous apportez
aux enfants qui dorment à la rue?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sarah Tanzilli
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Sarah Tanzilli: Merci.
Ma question,
à laquelle j'associe
la délégation pour le droit
des femmes, s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
Depuis ce lundi,
et ce jusqu'à la fin
de l'année, les femmes
travaillent gratuitement.
Derrière ce chiffre,
il faut voir
une inégalité
professionnelle
entre les femmes
et les hommes persistante
et multifactorielle.
A travail équivalent,
la différence
de revenus tombe sous les 5%.
Ce différentiel peut
et doit être traité
par les entreprises
vertueuses en matière.
C'est l'objet
de l'index mis en place
par cette majorité.
Cela force les entreprises
à calculer
le niveau d'inégalité
des employés
et à l'assumer publiquement.
A temps plein
identique, les femmes
sont payées
en moyenne 15%
de moins que les hommes.
Elles occupent des emplois
moins rémunérateurs
qui sont pourtant
nécessaires
à notre société.
Il nous faut
revaloriser ces métiers
et enjoindre
les femmes à rejoindre
des formations
de plus grande valeur.
Les femmes
sont les plus touchées
par le temps partiel subi.
Est-ce vraiment
un choix
si elles le font
pour s'acquitter
de leur second emploi
domestique non rémunéré?
L'inégalité
professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes
est déterminante.
Malgré des avancées
dans ce domaine,
notamment l'allongement
du congé paternité,
la situation demeure
insatisfaisante.
Quelles mesures supplémentaires
comptez-vous prendre
pour réduire
les inégalités salariales
entre les femmes et les hommes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la ministre
en charge
de l'Egalité
entre les femmes
et les hommes.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci.
15%, c'est ce que pèse
la société patriarcale
sur le revenu salarial des femmes.
Trop de femmes
sont cantonnées aux métiers
peu valorisés.
Trop de femmes subissent
le temps partiel.
La maternité
constitue
encore pour trop de femmes
un facteur
de précarité et un frein
dans leur carrière.
Nous devons atteindre
l'égalité salariale,
briser le plafond
de verre, améliorer
la mixité professionnelle
et rééquilibrer la charge parentale.
Nous avons fait
beaucoup dans le privé
et dans le public
en instaurant
des quotas.
Nous avons amélioré
les congés maternité
et paternité.
Avec Aurore Bergé,
nous déployons
le service public
de la petite enfance.
Pour lutter
contre les inégalités
salariales,
nous avons mis en place
un index professionnel
qui oblige
les entreprises
à une obligation
de résultat,
et non plus seulement
de moyens.
Cela a été confirmé
par la Première ministre.
Cet index sera
retravaillé et renforcé
dans les 18 prochains mois.
Il permettra aussi
la mise en place
d'un outil plus ambitieux
et plus transparent.
Il doit devenir un outil
pour la négociation d'entreprise.
Les femmes doivent
aussi se tourner
vers les métiers
d'avenir,
qui sont mieux rémunérés.
C'est tout l'enjeu
du programme
que je porte
et qui a pour objectif
d'accompagner 10.000
jeunes femmes
dans les études de la tech.
C'est notre objectif
de faire reculer
chaque année cette date
et d'aplatir
les inégalités qu'elle reflète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Marine Hamelet
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Marine Hamelet:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Je souhaite aujourd'hui
être la porte-parole
des agriculteurs
du Tarn-et-Garonne,
que j'ai rencontrés
à travers
leurs représentants syndicaux
vendredi dernier.
Leur exaspération
est à son comble.
Depuis votre prise
de fonction,
vous n'avez quasiment rien fait.
La situation s'est détériorée.
Les agriculteurs
disent à votre propos:
"Il nous écoute
mais il ne nous entend pas."
Les belles paroles
que vous leur donnez restent
lettre morte.
Les problèmes,
vous les connaissez pourtant.
Concurrence déloyale
avec d'autres pays:
ce qui est interdit
chez nous est autorisé ailleurs.
Normes punitives,
persécution administrative,
augmentation des prix
de l'énergie, augmentation
de la redevance sur l'eau...
Cela va conduire
à des milliers de faillites.
D'après des syndicats
d'agriculteurs,
dans les deux prochaines
années,
la moitié des exploitations
du Tarn-et-Garonne auront disparu.
Mettez-vous à la place
de ces hommes
et de ces femmes qui ont reçu
une exploitation
de leurs parents
ou de leurs grands-parents
et qui, demain,
ne pourront les transmettre
à leurs enfants.
Ils sont pris en tenaille
entre la hausse
des productions
et la baisse des prix
de vente.
Avez-vous conscience
que cette profession est à l'agonie?
Il faut prendre
des mesures concrètes
et durables pour sauver
cette profession
qui assure notre souveraineté
alimentaire.
Merci de préciser
ce que le gouvernement compte
faire en urgence
pour nos agriculteurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Vous faites une parfaite
démonstration,
au fond, de ce qu'est
la facilité
ou le populisme.
C'est la capacité à faire
des grandes phrases
et des grandes
récriminations
et à ne pas agir.
Ca va me permettre
de vous faire
une proposition.
Vous nous demandez d'agir.
Il va y avoir un projet
de loi
dans lequel il y aura
un budget supplémentaire
pour l'agriculture
pour faire face
à de nombreuses crises.
J'espère que vous allez
voter ces crédits.
Après, il faudra
retourner
devant les agriculteurs
pour leur expliquer
que sur la grippe aviaire
et sur certains dégâts
qu'ils ont subis,
vous ne les
avez pas accompagnés.
800 millions d'euros
en fin de gestion
pour couvrir ces dégâts.
On parle et on agit,
contrairement
à vous, me semble-t-il.
Vous ne l'avez pas
dit,
mais il y a eu
une grave tempête
dans le Tarn-et-Garonne,
cette année.
Nous nous sommes réunis
et nous avons fait
en sorte de couvrir
tous les besoins.
Nous avons mis en place
un fonds d'urgence
et les collectivités
locales
vont nous accompagner
pour faire
en sorte
que les arboriculteurs
puissent retrouver
la voie de l'optimisme
et d'un bon chemin économique.
Vous êtes dans un territoire
qui subit
de plein fouet l'impact
du dérèglement climatique.
Vous devriez
faire en sorte
qu'on les accompagne
dans les transitions
pour qu'elles puissent
avoir accès
à l'eau dans de meilleures
conditions,
pour qu'elles puissent
investir et améliorer leur matériel.
C'est comme ça
que l'on va accompagner
l'agriculture.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Marine Hamelet:
Vous me parlez
de mesures ponctuelles
et je vous parle
de réformes structurelles!
Les agriculteurs
ne cherchent pas l'aumône,
ils cherchent
à vivre dignement
de leur travail!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Philippe Nilor.
- Jean-Philippe Nilor:
Monsieur le ministre
des Outre-mer, le régime
spécifique d'approvisionnement
du RSA vise à faciliter
l'approvisionnement
de nos territoires
dits d'outre-mer.
Unanimement,
les filières concernées
de tous nos territoires
n'ont eu
de cesse d'alerter l'Etat
sur l'insuffisante dotation
de cette enveloppe,
dont le plafond
est bloqué à 27
millions depuis 2013.
Cela laisse apparaître
un manque global flagrant
de près de 8 millions d'euros.
En dépit des engagements
réitérés
par votre gouvernement
à augmenter
cette dotation,
les actes se font cruellement
attendre
alors qu'il y a urgence
et que Bruxelles attend
votre notification.
Dans un contexte marqué
par la vie chère
et par des taux
de chômage endémiques,
par l'inflation galopante
et par l'augmentation impériale
des importations,
vos tergiversations
ne font qu'aggraver
ce fléau en générant
une augmentation des prix
des produits locaux
et la mise en péril
des emplois directs
de ces filières.
Cela nous écarte
chaque jour
un peu plus des objectifs
de souveraineté
et de sécurité alimentaire,
pourtant omniprésente
dans vos discours.
J'affirme que nos pays
n'ont pas vocation
à demeurer sempiternellement
des terres d'importation
de produits finis
au détriment
de toute production locale.
Ma question est claire et précise.
Elle attend de votre part
une réponse claire
et précise.
Etes-vous prêt
à répondre favorablement
à cette demande
légitime d'abondement
du RSA de 8 millions d'euros?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
je connais votre engagement
pour l'agriculture.
On a eu ce débat
en commission l'autre jour.
Je vais vous répondre sans détour.
Vous savez très bien
que ce gouvernement aide
l'agriculture.
Pour les départements
d'outre-mer,
notre aide est prolongée à 280
millions d'euros.
En 2024, une aide
va provenir
de la France
et va augmenter de 33%.
Dans ce POSEI,
il y a deux jambes:
une jambe pour aider
les exploitations
et une jambe
qui est ce fameux RSA.
Vous avez raison,
il est bloqué
depuis 2013.
Il sert à amortir
les surcoûts dus
à l'importation
de produits qui servent
à nourrir les animaux.
Il faut une démarche partagée.
Les calculs nous disent
qu'il faudrait 7
à 8 millions
de plus d'ici 2030
pour faciliter
la souveraineté alimentaire.
D'ores et déjà,
les collectivités
comme la région
Guyane ont donné
leur accord.
J'imagine que vous serez
un ambassadeur
pour la Martinique.
Je suis persuadé
qu'avec le ministre
de l'Agriculture,
nous allons trouver
les moyens.
Je ferai tout pour faire
en sorte
qu'on dégèle cette somme
qui est bloquée
depuis 2013.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Elie Califer
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Elie Califer: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Le réchauffement climatique
est désormais une réalité.
En à peine deux semaines,
la Guadeloupe
a subi avec effroi le passage
dévastateur d'une tempête
et d'un ouragan.
Permettez-moi
d'avoir une pensée
pour les sinistrés
et d'exprimer
ma reconnaissance
à l'égard des services
de secours des collectivités
territoriales.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Elle porte à la fois
sur l'urgence
et sur l'avenir.
L'urgence commande de prendre
l'arrêté reconnaissant l'état
de catastrophe naturelle.
Plus de deux semaines
après votre engagement,
il se fait encore attendre.
Le temps est venu
pour le gouvernement
de répondre
à des problématiques
qui se posent après chaque événement
climatique majeur.
En Guadeloupe,
seuls quelques assureurs acceptent
d'assurer les biens
et les entreprises.
L'offre est plurielle
dans l'Hexagone.
Comment comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre
les préconisations du rapport
de 2020 concernant
la problématique
assurantielle ultramarine
sans faire
exploser les coûts
pour nos concitoyens?
Après beaucoup
de rencontres
dans ma circonscription,
il est nécessaire d'agir
sur plusieurs points.
Il faut agir sur l'entretien
des cours d'eau
et sur les travaux
dans les ravins
et les rivières.
Des dizaines d'ouvrages
sont à reconstruire
dans plusieurs villes.
Etes-vous prêt à créer un fonds
spécial d'aménagement résilient
pour nos territoires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
depuis le début
de cette séance,
on parle malheureusement beaucoup
de ces ouragans terribles.
On a parlé
de la tempête Ciaran
et des décès qui ont eu lieu.
J'étais venu
en Guadeloupe suite
au passage d'un ouragan.
Nous n'avions pas eu
de victime à déplorer.
Vous savez que l'engagement
des services
de l'Etat est total.
Il nous faut
tirer des leçons
de tout cela.
Cela passe par la résilience.
Il faut en tirer
des leçons de manière
à mieux appréhender
ces événements.
Cette tempête était terrible.
Nous avons des outils,
vous les connaissez.
Sous le contrôle
de Christophe Béchu,
il y a des fonds
verts qui peuvent
être utilisés,
comme ils l'ont été
en 2023 et comme ils le seront
en 2024.
Ces fonds, il faut les mobiliser.
Ils sont parfaitement
adaptés aux situations
que vous évoquez.
Il y a eu le plan Séisme Antilles.
Il est à disposition
des collectivités.
Il faut tirer des leçons
sur les constructions.
Il faut tirer
des leçons sur comment
nous devons appréhender
ces nouveaux séismes
et ces ouragans
toujours plus violents.
Ces fonds existent,
nous les mobilisons
et vous savez très bien
que le gouvernement,
par le dispositif
catastrophe naturel,
sera présent là où il doit l'être.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Elie Califer:
Je vous demandais
des actions concrètes.
Vous m'avez fait un cours
de communication.
Il faudra aménager
autrement les territoires
et le fonds ne suffira pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Frédéric Valletoux.
- Frédéric Valletoux:
Ma question s'adresse
à la secrétaire
d'Etat chargée
de la Ville et de la Citoyenneté.
Le sport permet
à chacun de se réaliser
dans l'effort et de s'émanciper.
A moins d'un an
des Jeux Olympiques
de Paris, ai-je
besoin de rappeler
le caractère
universel des valeurs
du sport et le respect
des valeurs républicaines
dans le sport?
Celles-ci
sont de plus en plus contestées,
notamment par des clubs
franciliens de basket-ball.
Près de 70 clubs de basket
de la région Ile-de-France
contestent le règlement
de leur Fédération nationale
en souhaitant autoriser
le couvre-chef sportif
pour les compétitions féminines.
J'ai été alerté
par Valérie Pécresse
et son vice-président
chargé des sports,
qui mène un combat
ferme depuis 2017
sur le respect
de la laïcité
dans la région.
Pourtant,
la fédération de basket
est une des rares
fédérations en France
qui a pris ses responsabilités
en édictant
des règles claires là-dessus.
Le Conseil d'Etat,
par une décision
de juin dernier,
a rappelé
que c'est aux fédérations
sportives d'appliquer
le principe de neutralité
de service public.
C'est aux acteurs de terrain,
arbitres, entraîneurs,
qu'il revient au quotidien
de faire face
à des atteintes aux valeurs
de la République.
Je sais que le gouvernement
est attaché
à la laïcité stricte.
On l'a vu avec l'annonce
qui interdit
de porter le voile
pour les membres
de la délégation française
aux prochains JO.
Comment comptez-vous
obtenir
que les fédérations édictent
des règles claires
et précises pour garantir
la laïcité?
Ne serait-il pas opportun
de définir
un cadre légal
et national sur le port
de signes religieux
qui s'appliquerait
à l'ensemble des compétitions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Sabrina
Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache:
Monsieur
le député
Frédéric Valletoux,
la République est régulièrement
la cible d'organisations
politico-religieuses
qui testent
les principes républicains.
Dès 2021,
nous nous sommes dotés
de nombreux outils
pour respecter
les principes de la République.
La réponse du gouvernement
est claire: fermeté,
lucidité et vigilance.
Sur les 3500 contrôles
de clubs sportifs,
27 ont donné lieu
à des signaux faibles
de séparatisme.
Pour y faire face,
nous avons arrêté
un plan d'action
dont je ne citerai
que les principales
mesures: déploiement
d'un réseau de référents
pour éviter
la radicalisation,
programmation
de 6000 contrôles
dans les clubs sportifs...
La récente décision du Conseil
d'Etat vient consolider
le principe de laïcité
dans le sport.
Elle appelle
à une analyse au cas
par cas
avec des restrictions,
le cas échéant.
Je tiens à faire
primer les principes
de la République
sous le contrôle
du ministère des Sports
et avec l'appui
du ministère de l'Intérieur.
Nous serons à leurs côtés
pour les accompagner.
La main
du gouvernement
ne tremblera pas face
aux attaques
de notre pacte républicain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Serva.
- Olivier Serva: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
des Outre-mer délégué,
il y a quelques semaines,
une étudiante guadeloupéenne
en région lyonnaise
m'a transféré
un mail qui m'a scandalisé.
Sur ce mail,
il est indiqué
par une agence immobilière
du groupe Foncia:
"Les conditions
de la garantie loyers impayés
ne permettent pas de présenter
un garant
qui ne réside pas en France
métropolitaine.
Avez-vous un autre
garant à présenter?
Sinon, nous ne pourrons pas
vous attribuer l'appartement".
J'ai une question.
Existe-t-il une présomption
d'insolvabilité,
d'incapacité
à subvenir aux besoins
de leurs enfants
en études,
pour les parents ultramarins?
Comment un enfant
qui a des parents ultramarins
fait pour trouver
un logement
sur un territoire
où il ne connaît personne?
Monsieur le ministre,
l'installation d'étudiants
ultramarins
en poursuite d'études
en Hexagone relève
du parcours du combattant.
Pourtant, un article de la loi
du 6 juillet 89 interdit
aux bailleurs de refuser
une caution bancaire
au motif
qu'elle n'est pas domiciliée
dans l'Hexagone.
Cette discrimination
tombe sous le coup
des articles du code
pénal concernés.
Elle est passible
de 45.000 euros d'amende
et de 3 ans d'emprisonnement.
Nous voulons
une application stricte
de la loi par les assurances
et bailleurs.
Nous ne sommes pas
des bâtards
de la République.
Quelles sont les actions
de contrôle
que votre gouvernement
compte mettre
en place pour faire
appliquer
cette loi et faire cesser
ces discriminations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Monsieur le député Olivier Serva,
en découvrant
cette histoire,
je trouve cela intolérable.
Une faute a été commise
par cette agence.
Elle avait une caution familiale.
Elle aurait dû
bénéficier,
comme un étudiant hexagonal,
de la possibilité
d'un logement.
Il n'y a aucune excuse
à donner
à une telle démarche.
Vous savez que les étudiants
sont 86.000
à avoir des parents ultramarins.
Ils ont des dispositifs en place.
Leurs bourses
augmentent
plus que les bourses
pour les étudiants
de l'Hexagone.
Nous permettrons
à ces étudiants
de rentrer dans leur famille.
Dès les vacances de Noël,
que les étudiants soient boursiers
ou non, il y aura
une prise en charge
pour qu'ils puissent
rentrer chez eux.
Pour les fameuses
cautions
dont vous parliez,
il y a une caution
qui permet d'échapper
à la caution parentale.
C'est l'Etat qui apporte
cette caution.
Partout, pour élargir
la palette
de formations, proposer
une meilleure mobilité,
le gouvernement est là.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Christine Decodts.
- Christine Decodts:
Madame la ministre
de la Citoyenneté
et de la Ville,
5,4 millions d'habitants
en France résident
dans les quartiers
prioritaires
de la politique de la ville.
Le comité interministériel
des villes
du 27 octobre veut marquer
une nouvelle étape
dans la politique
de la ville,
avec le lancement d'une nouvelle
génération nommée Engagement
quartiers 2030.
Il s'agit d'une simplification
et d'une accélération,
d'ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives
pour ouvrir l'accès à tous
les services publics,
le plein emploi
et la transition écologique.
Dans ces quartiers où il fait
trop chaud l'été
et trop froid l'hiver,
où la sobriété énergétique
est plus souvent
subie que choisie,
dans ces quartiers
où l'angoisse
des charges
et des futures factures
de chauffage vient amputer
des familles déjà mises
à mal par les difficultés
de la vie quotidienne,
quelles mesures
allez-vous porter
en termes d'écologie du quotidien?
Quelles sont vos priorités
pour la période 2024-2030?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Sabrina
Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Madame la députée,
vous m'interrogez
sur les mesures
en matière d'écologie
du quotidien pour les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville.
Je vous en remercie.
Cette question
a longtemps été cantonnée
à un seul sujet,
celui de la rénovation énergétique
des logements.
Si cette dimension
est importante,
il est indispensable,
selon moi,
d'avoir une vision
plus ambitieuse.
C'est ce que porte
le gouvernement,
sous l'autorité
de la Première ministre
et du comité
interministériel,
qui a proposé des mesures fortes.
Il s'agit du doublement
de la part
du fonds vert inscrit
dans les quartiers.
Nous allons
sensibiliser les jeunes
aux enjeux de la biodiversité.
Le gouvernement veut
permettre le déploiement
des mobilités
douces et durables
en expérimentant
le recours automatique
à la tarification
sociale et solidaire,
en matière de transports
en commun.
Ces actions spécifiques
jouent sur l'ensemble
des leviers possibles
pour rendre
nos quartiers plus verts.
Lorsque l'on met
plus d'humain,
plus d'opportunités
et de lien, on permet
une amélioration des choses.
Nous voulons agir
pour la mixité sociale,
aider à l'attribution
de logements sociaux
ou renforcer
l'accès aux soins,
par exemple.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Christine Decodts:
J'accueille
avec intérêt ces mesures.
Je réponds favorablement
à votre invitation
et je compte
sur les services de l'Etat
pour déployer,
avec les acteurs locaux,
les mesures prises auprès
des territoires concernés
et de leurs habitants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Caroline Colombier.
- Caroline Colombier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
Alors que chaque jour,
nos territoires ruraux luttent
contre les départs
des médecins,
contre la fermeture
des commerces
de proximité, des écoles,
des services publics,
les voilà maintenant
frappés par l'explosion
de l'insécurité
et du trafic de drogue.
Si le phénomène
n'est pas nouveau,
il s'amplifie chaque année
et empoisonne
la vie des habitants.
En Charente,
où je suis élue,
les communes rurales
sont devenues
le théâtre de règlements
de comptes, d'agressions,
d'enlèvements,
de menaces et de pressions
sur les riverains.
Le nombre
de consommateurs explose.
Les jeunes
sont des cibles faciles
pour ces nouveaux
cartels de la drogue
qui sévissent
dans ces campagnes rongées
par la précarité
et l'effondrement
du pouvoir d'achat.
Les saisies
sont de plus en plus régulières.
Les enquêteurs sont débordés.
On parle de plusieurs dizaines
de tonnes saisies.
Je félicite le travail
des services
de gendarmerie
et de police, qui font
un travail remarquable.
Cependant, cela n'est pas assez.
Ce ne sont pas les nouvelles
brigades
du tigre de gendarmerie
annoncées
par le président
qui suffiront à éradiquer
ce fléau.
Vous n'avez rien fait
contre la drogue
des villes.
Qu'en sera-t-il
de la drogue des champs?
La passivité
du gouvernement
est du pain béni pour les dealers.
Monsieur le ministre,
maintenant
que la drogue est dans le pré,
que comptez-vous faire
pour lutter contre ce fléau
qui gangrène
nos campagnes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sabrina
Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Madame la députée Colombier,
vous m'interrogez
sur l'amplification
du trafic de stupéfiants
dans les communes rurales.
La lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants
est une priorité du gouvernement.
Aucune différence
n'est faite
entre les territoires
urbains et ruraux.
Notre action est déterminée
pour combattre
ce fléau.
Cette action est fondée
sur un plan d'aide
à lutter contre le trafic
de stupéfiants.
Pour l'année 2022,
nos résultats enregistrés
par la gendarmerie
sont très positifs.
Même si nous aspirons
à frapper toujours
plus fort, car on n'en fera
jamais assez
contre le trafic
de drogue, 15,5 tonnes
de résine ou d'herbe
de cannabis
ont été saisies en 2022,
soit le double
par rapport à 2021.
Je peux aussi
reprendre l'exemple
du travail que les forces
de l'ordre
ont accompli récemment
dans votre département, la Charente.
Les trafics de stupéfiants
s'insinuent également
dans nos campagnes.
Nous avons le devoir,
ensemble,
de les combattre,
et lutter
contre ce fléau
reste une priorité
pour nous.
Police et gendarmerie
se mobilisent quotidiennement
pour la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue.
Il manque un mot
dans votre question:
la prévention. La prévention
contre les conduites addictives,
qui touchent les quartiers
prioritaires et les campagnes.
C'est une des priorités
du ministère
de la Citoyenneté.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une réponse?
-
Caroline Colombier:
Il ne faut pas attendre
d'en faire
des zones de non-droit
ou des zones
de non-France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sarah Legrain.
- Sarah Legrain:
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
le 7 janvier, Lucas,
13 ans, mettait fin à ses jours.
Nous nous demanderons
toujours
si ce drame aurait pu être évité.
Combien de drames
et de souffrances,
qui frappent quotidiennement
des jeunes, pourraient être évités?
J'ai lu votre plan harcèlement.
Je n'y vois pas une ligne
sur l'éducation
à la vie affective et sexuelle.
Dans votre budget non plus,
je ne vois rien.
Les rapports officiels,
les chefs d'établissement,
les infirmières scolaires,
les parents alertent.
La loi n'est pas respectée.
Seuls 15 à 20%
des élèves reçoivent
cette éducation.
Un collectif, hier,
au Sénat, présentait
son livre blanc
pour une véritable éducation
à la sexualité,
avec des contenus harmonisés,
adaptés à chaque âge.
Vous n'étiez pas là,
monsieur le ministre.
Récemment, une coalition
de parents s'est prononcée
contre l'éducation
sexuelle à l'école.
L'éducation sexuelle
protège les enfants
des violences.
Elle permet
d'apprendre le respect
du consentement,
des valeurs
que ces enfants
ne voient pas toujours
autour d'eux.
J'ai vu des jeunes
gens libérés
de leurs interrogations,
de leurs préjugés,
grâce à des espaces
de dialogue créés
par des associations,
sur un terrain
où parents et professeurs
sont souvent démunis.
L'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle protège,
mais elle est menacée
par votre inaction politique
et par les agissements
de l'extrême droite.
De quoi avez-vous peur?
Qu'allez-vous faire
de nos recommandations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran...
Pardon, à monsieur Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la députée
Sarah Legrain,
quand 1 garçon sur 3 déclare
penser qu'une femme peut aimer
être forcée
à une relation sexuelle,
on voit qu'il y a un problème.
Quand,
dans une enquête,
on voit que plus de 40%
des garçons déclarent que s'informer
sur le sexe passe
par les contenus pornographiques
sur Internet,
c'est qu'il y a un problème.
C'est un problème
de société, qui dépasse
largement l'Education nationale.
Nous y travaillons.
L'Education nationale
doit contribuer à y répondre.
Ce sujet doit être dépassionné
politiquement.
Je ne crois pas que vous servez
la cause
en politisant ce sujet.
Je pense qu'il faut
de la transparence.
de la transparence
en direction des familles.
Je pense qu'il faut
de la concertation
et de la méthode.
Brouhaha
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît!
Madame Legrain,
écoutez le ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
La méthode est claire.
Nous avons un conseil
supérieur
des programmes,
chargé de l'élaboration
qui a été missionné
en juin dernier,
avant mon arrivée
au ministère, pour faire
des propositions
et des recommandations
sur les programmes
en la matière.
Le conseil supérieur
des programmes doit remettre
des propositions d'ici
la fin de l'année.
Pour élaborer
ses recommandations,
il échange avec l'ensemble
des acteurs.
Le livre blanc
que vous avez évoqué fera partie
des travaux qui vont participer
à l'élaboration
des programmes.
Nous aurons
l'occasion de prendre
des décisions adaptées
grâce à cela.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vigier.
- Jean-Pierre Vigier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de la Transition
écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Trop peu, trop tard
et trop compliqué,
voilà comment le comité
des finances locales qualifie
le filet de sécurité
mis en place
pour aider les communes
à faire face
à la crise inflationniste.
Cet outil de sécurité
est apparu
comme une usine
à gaz, qui exclut
des collectivités
confrontées à la flambée
des prix de l'énergie.
Ce filet de sécurité
ne fait qu'aggraver
ce triste résultat.
En lieu et place
des 22.000 communes
qui devaient toucher
une dotation,
moins de 3000
sont finalement concernées.
C'est 8 fois moins que le nombre
initial prévu.
Beaucoup de ces communes
vont devoir rembourser
tout ou partie
de l'acompte
qu'elles ont reçu au titre
de ce dispositif.
Cette nouvelle déconvenue
entérine l'échec
du filet de sécurité.
Elle acte le mépris
adressé aux élus locaux
qui n'ont jamais
démérité pour faire face
aux tensions budgétaires.
Loin d'améliorer
les conditions économiques
des communes, cet
arrêté va enfoncer
de nombreux maires
dans l'inquiétude.
Il faut en finir
avec ces méthodes mesquines
qui privent les maires
de leur pouvoir d'agir
et de leur capacité d'initiative.
Allez-vous réellement exiger
ces remboursements,
au risque d'accentuer
la précarité financière
de nos collectivités
territoriales?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
je sais votre attachement
aux collectivités territoriales.
Disons les choses concrètement.
Ce filet de sécurité,
l'article 14
de la loi de finances
rectificatives...
Qui a été dans cet hémicycle?
Il y avait trois conditions
cumulatives:
avoir une épargne brute
qui soit inférieure
à 22%, un potentiel
fiscal inférieur
à plus de la moitié
et une baisse
de l'épargne brute.
Je ne peux pas croire
que vous expliquiez
que vous considérez
qu'on ne doit
pas appliquer la loi.
La loi disait
qu'il y a trois critères
d'application.
Nous avons constaté
qu'il y avait 3000 communes
pour 450 millions d'euros.
La conséquence
que nous avons tirée,
ici également,
de cela,
c'est que c'est un filet
de sécurité
qui n'est pas de 450
millions,
mais de 1,5 milliard d'euros
pour l'année 2023,
avec non plus trois critères
de porte d'entrée,
mais un seul.
En revanche,
ce que la loi a décidé
en août 2022,
le gouvernement l'applique
sur la base du vote du Parlement.
Nous avons amélioré
le dispositif
pour l'année en cours,
en décembre dernier.
Vous ne pouvez pas
nous demander
de manière rétroactive
de réécrire
les critères tels
qu'ils avaient été décidés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-Pierre Vigier:
Il faut corriger
ces critères.
Nos communes en ont besoin.
Elles font un travail
exemplaire
et sont fragiles
et pénalisées, aujourd'hui.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
nous avons corrigé
ces critères
pour l'année en cours.
La somme
que nous avions accordée,
qui était de 450
millions,
elle est quasiment
celle qui a été attribuée
par le décret du 13 octobre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Elodie
Jacquier-Laforge.
- Elodie Jacquier-Laforge: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture
et de l'Alimentation,
Marc Fesneau.
Si je vous dis parisienne,
franquette, lara,
à quoi pensez-vous?
A la noix de Grenoble.
Je parle de la culture de la noix.
Elle est affectée
par le changement climatique,
la sécheresse, les tempêtes.
Elle accumule
toutes les difficultés.
En 2022, la récolte
a été exceptionnelle,
avec une production de 30
à 40% supérieure
à la normale.
Du jamais vu.
Mais cette production
remarquable,
en France et dans les autres
pays producteurs
de noix, s'est accompagnée
d'une baisse massive
de la consommation
mondiale de ce fruit
à coque.
Les prix se sont écroulés.
En 2023, nouveau coup dur:
une récolte exceptionnellement
basse plonge
les cultivateurs
dans la difficulté.
Il faut développer
des moyens de production
plus neutres et efficaces
en termes d'atteinte
à l'environnement.
C'est ainsi qu'a été créée
la station d'expérimentation
nucicole en Rhône-Alpes.
L'absence de véritable
structure
de la filière,
aujourd'hui, expose
à une particulière
fragilité nos producteurs de noix.
Je souhaiterais
connaître les mesures
que vous souhaitez
mettre en place
pour accompagner cette filière.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Je vais rappeler
ce qu'est la filière noix
en France:
c'est le deuxième verger
après les pommes, 25.000 hectares.
La France est le quatrième
exportateur mondial
pour les cerneaux et les noix.
Malgré cela,
la filière noix traverse
une crise conjoncturelle
et une crise structurelle.
Il nous faut
répondre à la crise
du moment,
car les aléas climatiques
ont fait
qu'il y a trop de production
ou pas assez.
Il y a aussi des baisses
de consommation.
La consommation de noix
au niveau mondial
est plutôt sur une tendance
croissante.
On répond à cette crise
au travers
de dispositifs comme la réserve
de crise européenne.
L'Europe va apporter des moyens.
C'est 10 millions
d'euros pour la cerise
et la noix.
Il y aura 2 millions
de crédits nationaux
en complément
qui permettront d'aider
les nuciculteurs.
Leurs pertes
pourront être prises
en charge dans le cadre
de ces dispositifs.
Nous allons
faire en sorte
que le plus grand nombre
de nuciculteurs puissent
en bénéficier.
Il faut répondre
à la crise immédiate
mais aussi à la crise
structurelle.
Il faut avoir une production
qui réponde
à la demande.
On produit beaucoup
de fruits à coque
par nature, mais on doit
exporter plutôt
des cerneaux
car c'est le marché
qui est tendance.
Il faut qu'on arrive
à mieux transformer
la noix.
Il faut que les producteurs
s'organisent mieux.
Ca leur permettra d'accéder
à un certain nombre
de fonds qui permettront
de moderniser
les outils de production,
de faire
de la valorisation de la noix.
Notre pays consomme
assez peu de noix.
On a besoin de faire
des campagnes
de communication.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.